- Do you ever get tired, and what do you?
- DRock, can you believe this today?
We've had a very weird day.
This has come up like four times today.
- Since the last DailyVee,
this could be like a whole
fun thing to do, right?
What happened?
I went to the West Coast.
Went to Super Bowl.
Spent some great time with Stephen Ross,
owner of the Miami Dolphins,
my business partner
bought into VaynerMedia
several years ago.
And, you know, he's an NFL owner.
You know I like that.
So, got to spend some nice time
with him at the Super Bowl.
- Is that Brandon Marshall?
- [Brandon] I love you, man.
- [Gary] How are you, my friend?
- [Brandon] Gary V.
- We're going live.
We're live on Facebook.
- How is that possible?
- Because you know how I do these things.
This is called Facebook Live.
We need to get you on this.
- This guy's the king of social media.
If you're not following
this guy, you ought to.
(laughs)
- Then I went and had some meetings in LA.
Followed up with a trip to San Diego.
Let New York know I'm in San Diego.
Spoke at a large digital
conference, which I enjoyed.
Very well organized.
Hey Corporate America assholes,
this is how everybody now watches TV.
They're raising their hand,
because they don't watch it when it airs,
which means they're not watching
your fucking bullshit commercial.
Then I took a red-eye to Miami.
LAX hustle is super real.
Met with Lexus,
which is a division within Toyota,
which is a client of VaynerMedia's.
Gave a speech to senior executives there.
Did some podcasting.
Showed up in some social.
Did a lot of Snapchatting,
make sure you're following that.
And now getting really
focused on the book.
It's very close.
If you haven't ordered
your copies yet, please do.
If I've brought you any value in life,
an order would mean a lot to me.
We've got the Super 8 coming up.
Buy eight books, get a lotto
ticket for February 23rd.
So, focus today is see Steve Ross today.
- [Gary] Hello, Ben.
This is my DailyVee,
this is my video blog.
Yeah, how are you?
You don't want to be famous?
And that's exactly what's about to happen.
And Facebook, Twitter, and Tubmlr.
Facebook, Twitter, Youtube, and Instagram
are ABC, NBC, and CBS.
And what I've figured
out for the last decade,
is how to make Jujubes or Nilla Wafers,
which was flat for 11 years,
but with $800,000 I grew
12% with no support.
I've figured out how to make M A S H,
and the Andy Griffith
Show, and ER, and Seinfeld.
- And it's a lot more economic.
- It's not even close.
We'll connect. I'll see you right away.
You're the biggest at the thing that
I want to do for the rest of my life.
Interesting.
- [Ben] There's nothing
more fun than watching
Gary Vaynerchuk pitch.
- It should be a show in itself.
- It is a show.
- It's such a crazy feeling.
I don't even know.
- You don't even know what happens.
- Yeah, I black out.
I literally get possessed.
Big meeting about Resy,
our restaurant app.
It's going super well.
Steve, I'm gonna let Ben
do most of the talking,
but the reason we're together now is
we've got some real exciting
stuff going on with Resy.
- Do you have 10 minutes?
- We're running late.
- So, I'd like to be
like a strategy intern,
but I know that I can be an asset.
And I'm so certain that I can help,
and I'll work the first
month or two for free.
- Send me an email, I'll sit
with you for five minutes
in the next two weeks.
Good luck to you.
You're welcome, man.
Hello.
Oh, is this us?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Not this?
That guy wasn't happy with me.
- [Driver] How are you doing, sir?
- Good. How are you?
Going to LinkedIn.
That should be a lot of fun.
- Hey, guys. How are you?
- Hi.
- Gary, Noelle. So good to
see you again. How are you?
- How are things?
- So good, thank you.
Thank you for being here.
- Do you have a special talent?
Oh, I can do this with my tongue.
(audience laughs)
LinkedIn is a tremendous company,
and it'll be fun to speak
to some of their executives.
- Do you ever get tired, and what do you?
- DRock, can you believe this today?
We've had a very weird day.
This is come up like four times today.
- [Female Interviewer] You travel so much.
What are you tips and tricks
for overcoming jet lag?
- I don't have a trick.
I don't know what's happening.
It's called enormously lucky DNA.
No worries.
That's been the best part of DailyVee.
Now people really know
how busy I am, you know?
- [Male] I feel bad that we
have you here for an hour.
- What's up?
- My man.
- What's going on?
- Ready for your DailyVee?
Let's call it what it is.
Snapchat and DailyVee
are really just vehicles
for me to impose my will
on everybody to just,
once and for all, eliminate the converse.
I basically want people to be embarrassed.
- [Male] I can tell you
worked 12 hours today.
- [Gary] That is just, no.
Everybody should do their thing.
Just embarrassed to say
they do work as hard as me.
You might be smarter and make more money,
and you're better and you're better.
But the one thing you're allowed to say
is that you work harder.
- [Male] Do you think that
the idea of hustle culture
is becoming like cliche?
Like, the thing about your hustle is
it's hustle with tons of substance,
but I feel like there's a lot of kids
who are just hustling to hustle.
- [Gary] I think a lot of kids are saying
they're hustling to hustle,
you know what I mean?
- [Male] But that's what I'm getting at.
- [Gary] And by the way, I'm just doing it
to help the people that are
actually trying to do it,
realize how much work it is.
I actually hope somebody else
comes out with the DailyZee
and shows unbelievable work life balance.
Just shows her or his seven hour days,
but just enormous amounts
of happiness with family,
and bowling, and learning new.
I'm gonna learn how to knit this week.
I don't want to convince
anybody to do what I do.
I just want to clarify
to everybody that if.
- [Male] When you say hustle,
this is what you mean.
- [Gary] Yeah. Look it
takes a lot of work.
And you know the other
thing that's really helped
a lot of people is people are like,
"Whoa. You're already way
more successful than I am,
and I'm working like half as much as you.
And I thought I was working more than you,
because I thought you
were kind of saying it,
but then reaping the
benefits of the riches."
So, it's a context point.
So, it's come up because
of my last 24 hours
on Snap, I think.
Not really, you know.
Like once like four times a year,
I'll collapse and go to sleep at 7 p.m.
And I'll need a hardcore 15 hour sleep.
And I started taking care of
my health about two years ago,
18 months ago.
I don't think I've
picked up any more energy
when I was 25 pounds heavier,
and eating like shit, and not exercising.
I just had so much natural adrenaline.
I showed to somebody's podcast yesterday,
and he was Facebook Living
and I went back and read all the comments
last night at midnight,
because I don't get tired,
and literally everybody's like,
"This guy's on fucking drugs."
Which is really interesting.
And they meant it,
because they didn't know who I was.
They're like, "Why do all
these guys have to take drugs?"
And I was like, "Fuck, I've
never even tried a cigarette.
"I've never done anything in my life.
"I've been left out from
all that good shit."
And people still think it
because it's just natural DNA.
I truly think it's the
same way as being pretty
or six foot five.
It's just something you were given.
And I like it. I'm glad.
I really believe what I'm about to say,
and this is hyperbolized to the moon,
I truly think I'm the hardest
working person on Earth.
I truly believe that.
I just work 18 hours a day every day.
I just do.
Cool. Awesome.
Thanks guys.
(applause)
- [Female] All right. Gary,
Chip, thank you both so much.
LinkedIn, thank you.
Please thank them for
their incredible time.
- [Gary] Got a little internal meetings.
Got some late night drinks.
Should be a good day for 14. Episode 14.